here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a supporting role
when i heard my name called for the
first time in my life i kind of felt
like time stopped for a moment i felt
like i was in this like vortex
this is the first oscar and nomination
for mahershala ali
it was one of the most special things
i've ever experienced just to see so
many people out there that i admire and
and loved and appreciate and am inspired
by like clapping for me and for our film
so uh i still could get choked up about
it so uh yeah i'm a little speechless
now felt this how i felt speechless
um
wow
i managed to find some words to say i
just want to thank my wife who was in
her third trimester during award season
we just had a daughter four days ago
don't get pregnant during award season
and don't get your partner pregnant
during the word season it's already
crazy so you know you don't want to add
babies to that i just want to thank her
for being just such a soldier through
this process and and help and really
carrying me through it all so thank you
really appreciate it peace and blessings
i was amazed in awe of it all
you